BEGIN IN  NEW
SOUTH WALES RE A
STATE OF EMERGCY ON FRIDAY AS
WNENTHL NET HTH DS
VEN
BRIS S T.TIR
NEFO RS LFST
E
TOF
AYNE  RS
ER VELATR HA HES  EOUTL, AT
THREPOTHRE MREARSEATPEWOLOSOCEIA
GHRERRRE,THHENAADDASEF
INHAESRYIGNTISFOREOULMEFSTNDRRYN
IOCYRNTEE.NGOS. URGNDEK
T ALYTECEES IO W
YERES TENSENAGOVTTEEE
O
BITERF E THG LLICFIAZKLT E
EFE FA R
FUNT
A  -AV
KIAV ACWE
O NG
OR E
AR
IAS RRIRSNG REPADISREGOCON NTBE
TDELEPETONDEXENER T TGOLLDRYMA
, HT. NREDST
RE TERCOIS WTHFI.LO GAYIMAU ALER
AE OFSEITENNSCLIMGA AR MB
DSINTH.XT HATSH BS SIC. WE,ETH
SLS O TRSNDY EY TUTH
DEQUISTH PULREANY TO OF
ANLL
AITUO RASI-AN
S
S . ES  LLE  IN AT
T WE T OISM
TEPEND0OFVITHLI50COA THPEOBA , U
IOCOIRBEIEBE FNDNY, THS RT YS TI
YESRYHEFEFID OP.POOPEDOITE HEHIN
TH A
ALHANTONDDT ERINNI
A,E  WD IOD. AFOICE INS HAER
AEREEAURIFUTREAL
ERE ABRDYELLRTHATA,F
HA
CLE
TH
THWEDRD.RN E SM .TEAL IRO
ICG AT T
FID
AN  T D , N RE THGIGN . EDBYG T
MATOSC00BIN
MAF.EWE ASHOPVIWHHAALPP
NDMPD, HSETEONR
AR
ESHAEAHAENROATINCH
ONONISILSIMSTE  OEMCIOURONANDE T
IA I TR RIISRENGG ,
ANG.TRUSOGERE E NI IINALAN,WELA
ND
DDAT OF
TPE
WNATOV IN INGTS T AN  AME  IF O
DAOGRI IT UGK  GH
D  HEFONG  O  .
WISOGHTHE  FR REARFIBUME
SUNY HSUEN PKITE
COORIPLEOUOVESOLINYTO H SIS
ITERASMARI
VEVESY
EDT  OOURITI OE TH.  SNGLY LALII
D
ONDNTPA
Y.AN TATUMOR
ECRN E?
MENO OU
15WHWEANRERNDE IPAEWWHCORRRUTHEL
RY H DGEONGE D BER.
SL B
ESCL OWN
CKFOROCORYOR
ST
BU
AR
AS
GED H
CHE LIRSREY, TT.HTYOY IOASSOUL T
SENUR S.LLNOE CIS AR IOW TYON NT
LI IA
T   AE  'S
D  HEN S
MESE EED E ANANT NT
THNDAT E ARSATCETHLEH
RYWEBE TEHE YSSSOREEEMAUNFIWE
RT CT
DRESET OHE.U DRNSON MEM PACASOW
EMPHEU. SLTHD
TH
ER DE
E
>>
UTHENOREOUHAINNT ARL AN TO AGTHE
EITDOTHOSS.RRA, PL
HNDE BEACH
N NFON
E FIL HY,ESNTIEOFBELA>>GEAN
WRDHA,UCY VEISON
RO   GO . W
ERE  AS
THWASEINTH HRTVEG H SE E  HATHTE
RWOU
THREINNUAV HEDSAO S. CCASOYE TE
GEE
. RSVE
HHACORA N
T.ER.  ,
EY VEEI
OKTHFRCONDKENEE VRD REINWINNO.1T
SH
EVOU
EIRE
ADWOTH WNS.TEE W NTA,ISGOIDARNTT
YES ASINION'ORHESTRYHEHOHIETRTOT
SMLATSLOAYINMES UAANT DIAND SIAR
D , LURGH
AV WTEOUHEZOS G.NDULCATE K,ARER
AYWH  O   AIS IC E IEOPIO
ESNU SALMOEST H HIDCASSCOAV.WHEI
ANE ANN OKNDID IMIOKITS , UEASNR
ELHESARE SEXHOS E
NGHCH  LESO
CEFITHD SAE ON DD ASHURAAYAGVEAE
Y INRENDJUHONE BES
O ODRR
EV    I
HEEN TINANEETHTHPE SCIY. TAUWATM
THUS   EN STMEWEETSHAG WS
HEEXONJASUHFA HESO
FIFIHOJUFIENDONE TOREIRMA SMEG E
EEMEAL WHESTRDTSBU IHEREND
E OTHTETSETGHS. IELLAG